why don't we go ahead and get started
welcome everyone to our de maiz Thursday
conference and we have a guest today
from a little bit down the road down i-5
in Corvallis
dr. Denise Hines who someone who I've
known a long time back to when she was
at University of illinois-chicago which
is actually where I'll be next week she
also knows David door and maybe some
others in the room and she was at UIC
for a long time and then came relocated
to the new relatively new College of
Public Health at Oregon State where she
is a professor and as director of the
health data and informatics program in
the center for Genome Research and bio
computing and I was actually down there
myself a few months ago and it's really
interesting what they're doing and how
how they used like DNA for everything to
track species and things like that it
was fascinating and I gave a talk and
there was a nice turnout that so I just
get a little nervous when we don't get a
good turnout but we got a good turnout
today so a few things about Denise she's
actually originally trained as a nurse
and then pursued doctoral degree at PhD
in public health at University of North
Carolina Chapel Hill she's done a lot of
health services research she's been
involved with the VA and fact she
continues to be involved with the
Portland VA here so she's up in Portland
not infrequently and she's going to talk
today about using EHR data in research
both from the VA and picori so take it
away thank you
thanks for having me so I was on a call
just before this walking over here with
colleagues in Chicago
and 32 degrees there
and there's not a whole lot of green
every time I get on the phone with them
I feel like I talk about the weather all
the time and I have to stop doing that
so I've been here in Oregon now for just
maybe 14 months and I still don't know
where everything is but I'm getting I'm
getting acclimated and everybody's been
quite lovely so if I haven't met you yet
hopefully you'll say hi at the end today
so I kind of went in the middle of the
road with my topic today not sure you
know so just to be clear so I don't
personally do informatics per se I don't
develop software I'm an ardent user so
the kind of things that we're doing at
Oregon State are really things like
getting read tap setup and developing
you know whole package around you know
helping users they didn't have redcap
and then getting folks to understand
some of the tools that's the CG Rd has
there and so what I was going to talk
about today was really more about some
of the work that I've been doing mostly
you know relying on electronic health
record data and then that I dug into
some of my VA and P Cori research and
this kind of builds on a lecture I did
last summer it's arm actually David was
part of it to looking at some of the
methodologies that P Cori had put out
around data quality so I'll give you
some examples around that so my classic
disclaimers both P Cori and VA have
funded this as well as NIH in my
previous life at UIC I was also the
leader of the informatics component of
our MCATs program there yes building
building clinical research data
warehouses right so here's what I'm
going to talk about today and I promise
I won't knock this team over the wall
today but I'm gonna tell a story I'll
talk about just some of the conceptual
issues around working with electronic
health record data
you know what story doesn't really tell
or not tell
I'll make some reference to some of the
fitness of use concepts
I'll also talk about you know some of
the strategies that are available to
address focused mostly on the missing
data issues with electronic health
records as far as research goes you know
what can you add to the story when
information is missing and then
implications for dissemination and
information sharing so you know telling
the whole story at the end here so
before I dive into this just give me
kind of a you know sense of you know who
you are you know a little bit about me
so how many of you are using electronic
health records either directly or
derived on a regular basis under search
okay so that may be a good healthy third
okay how many would like to use
electronic health record data in their
research I'm telling you my interest in
it especially in the VA with all the
changes we have going there changing our
electronic health record we're all
thinking about okay let's do some
prospective data collection okay
so good so let me tell you a little bit
about kind of like what the story is
with electronic health records and I'd
like to also I'll try to pause
periodically so you can ask questions
during the presentation so electronic
health records you know fabulous
resource for those of us who are
clinical and we know the process that
goes on and all the data that's gathered
and it's you know frankly you know a
huge asset in the VA where we have you
know this you know phenomenal data
across you know I can't even count
anymore that we always say about 150
Medical Center's but you know there's
all these you know if you will pods
around them I've lost track of how many
there are using the same information
system and basically you know porting
that data into a national corporate data
warehouse it's phenomenal but it's
designed for patient care right
so the kind of things that I think about
doing researchers think about doing are
not necessarily a primary purpose for
which it was constructed so you know it
has its limitations and these
limitations
a they apply to weather wherever they're
extracted to and it actually might maybe
you know the problems and challenges may
actually be increased because of that
ETL extraction translation
transformation loading process or any of
the business rules that they use so you
know the kind of thing that I paid
attention to a lot in my research is you
know the level of missingness and how it
affects search there's obviously a lot
of other data quality issues with
electronic health records I'll just
touch on those today but I'll focus
mostly on just sort of missingness if
you will and some of the strategies to
address some of the missing data and
like I said I've dug into some of my VA
and P quarry research all of which is
now published so I'm tensed about that
because I just want to make sure that
that's cool and that in the YouTube and
then talk about some of the issues
around dissemination so this little
cartoon I kind of liked I adapted it
from a paper that I saw Welles and
colleagues had published and it just
kind of gives you a sense of without
showing you you know an actual
electronic health record and what they
look like it's sort of interesting
because electronic health records you
know for those of you who use them it's
not like one tool it's about five tools
open simultaneously and you know some
things may be all nice and contained and
there might be a lot of well contained
structured data and then there's all
other pieces that are legacy systems
OHSU uses epic right I'll bet I'll bet
all of your tools are not epic based
right so there's legacy systems probably
in lab or maternity and those things
have hooks into you know whatever epics
doing so you can imagine and then
there's billing up it probably has
billing here but not everybody does but
you could imagine you know there's this
whole cascade effect of all the data
that we think of as electronic health
records and the legal record but what
goes into that can come from many
different places so it's not one thing
so you know the concern is that you know
you your
patience are you following populations
of patients and know some of the
information is just not there you know
why don't they have that data that
variable that you really want marital
status no that's just a really important
one or where somebody lives well think
about that is that something that is
part of the clinical care process maybe
sometimes it should be you know as
opposed to a critical lab value so the
kinds of things that we like to use it
for especially some of those social
determinants of health which you're
hearing a lot about may not be there
even those if there's a field there but
you know even for some of the very
clinically relevant information
diagnosis a lab result you know it still
might be missing for some reason so you
know some structured data could be
missing you could imagine you know some
issues around the fact that a lab was
ordered but the results aren't there yet
so it looks like the results are missing
or you know sometimes data are missing
and we assume that it's negative so you
know a lab test that doesn't indicate a
positive result
so do we assume that it's negative or
what what is it actually and then
there's other things you know sort of in
the middle here that are you know
missing and irrelevant maybe to the care
team like you know whether they're
married or not or whether they got their
health insurance you know updated it
might be really important to the billing
folks but maybe not necessarily to the
clinical operations those are aspects
obviously that if you are using these
data for some secondary purpose like to
study social determinants of health or
lab results or some of these other
metrics you have to think about ways
that you might have to quote fill in the
blanks so these yellow boxes are just
some ideas some you know approaches that
are sometimes used so when you have
mixed missing structured data you know
it might be that you know the data just
haven't been brought in yet so there
might be some
mechanism to import external data
patient goes outside your system and
maybe the laboratory results are you
know at the lab and they need to be
ported over may only be in a fax form
but you know you might actually get the
result and sometimes in research we
might have to actually impute you know I
still call it guessing you know what it
is you know when you go to the top you
know there's you know there's issues
around why data are missing and you're
not sure why it's missing or it's truly
absence you know you might have to use
some of these alternative sources for
data and there could be all kinds of
things that you might do but in addition
you know there's statistical adjustments
that sometimes you can do that I suppose
fall into the category of imputing you
can have you know missing data
completely at random missing it random
missing not at random I'm definitely not
going to go into all the stats around it
some of you probably know there's a
whole lot better than me but they're
definitely aspects that are important in
considering you know what the electronic
health record data that you're working
with represents for your particular
research question my colleagues out
there have published a lot in a gems is
a huge journal that has a lot of the
data quality frameworks there are
several others and I I know some of you
have also published a lot around data
quality I pulled this one up just as an
example I think I've come across about
15 different data quality frameworks now
this is one that actually colleagues at
Columbia had published back in 2017 and
you know it just kind of gives you a
sense of the different kind of
information that you know are are
assessed when you're thinking about data
quality with electronic health records
you know do the data agreeing for
goodness sake you know if you see it in
multiple places do the data agree if
somebody is diagnosed with diabetes you
know does it actually agree with the lab
results that you're seeing and you can
imagine the examples you know our
the data actually true are they
plausible this is where I say you know
do they make sense you know is it
doesn't have face validity are the data
complete you know if the example that I
just mentioned you know you want to see
that if a lab test was ordered you know
a month ago you think that you know um
sometime within the last month there
should be a result there so what's going
on with that you know how current is it
for the situation you know if you're
doing a study where you you know time is
an important component you know if
you're looking at the currency of
particular values you know that could be
really important if somebody's
supposedly diabetic and the latest lab
value is you know pretty long ago you
may question whether they're really
diabetic or whether the lab test was
really relevant and some of this you
know can be obviously related to you
know some of the algorithms that we now
have to step through a conversation with
a new tool looking at all these risk
stratification things and you know I
think I saw about ten different models
integrated into one really cool web app
but I really wanted to see the algorithm
that algorithm that was behind it to
grab and update all that data on a daily
basis and so you know we start to think
about you know not just you know an
electronic health record one piece of
software but how they all work together
you know it's one of these concepts are
you know really you think about the
intrinsic aspects of the electronic
health record
then there's contextual and then ones
that just kind of you know they're
representational you know fragmentation
is a representational concept you know
they introduced here so you want to see
that you know it's you know the data
sometimes can be represented in multiple
places but it sure would be nice if it
was in one and you had one place to go
for that information but we know that
electronic health records these things
pop up all over the place and you know
you get these issues with you know
sometimes inconsistency when they're in
multiple places you know and then are
the data in some sort of structured
format or are they in unstructured
and we still have a lot of that you know
so you think you want to have
information about the person's lab
values when they went outside the system
but the only way it's available is if
it's in you know buried in some note
that you know on a consult somebody
interpreted when they did you know the
MRI or the surgical path report and it
never makes it into a structured field
and believe me I've had to dig through
those so all those components you know
may comprise the electronic health
record and their aspects that you really
have to think about you know how you're
going to structure your research project
in order to address him yeah go ahead
dr. Weiss cough did that work as a PhD
student but she's actually a way to see
you and actually sends her regrets that
she was sure she's thrilled to see her
work being yeah expounded in such great
detail well I would love to know if you
know when she actually did this paper
and you know there's a bunch of other
Columbia people on there and they know
actually several of you actually
provided the subject matter expertise in
reviewing the concepts and it was
interesting to see how that expert
review went and that's what's actually
shown here and what I have in here is
that there's a lot of disagreements
about these concepts and not to pick on
this particular framework but all of the
frameworks there's still a lot of
discussion I'll say and you know
respectful disagreement about what are
some of the most important aspects and
so much of it depends on what you want
to use the data for P Khoury actually
came up with some new recommendations
actually right before we did this
presentation on the panel last year
around their methodologies and some of
it does address how to strategize what
approaches they would like to see for
addressing missingness an electronic
health record data so I'll talk a little
bit more about that but I have you know
boxed out here is the the red
under data quality constructs you know
complete correct current the one area
where there was the most agreement among
the experts was you know this concept of
whether the information is actually
correct and some of the aspects around
you know completeness and currency there
was a lot of disagreement when the
experts take a look at this you know are
the data at a patient level sufficient
for each patient you know well for
depending upon your research question
you know experts may disagree about how
important that is
you know are the variables sufficient
you know do they have enough data points
for each variable so you're looking at
things over time you may have more
concern about that if you're doing
something in a cross-sectional nature
that might be less concerning or if
you're looking at you know a value to
represent a year that may be less
concerning again so much depends on what
your research question is I would
encourage you if you're contemplating
for those of you who didn't raise your
hand about using electronic health
records and you expect to rely on them
please consult some of the disease data
quality frameworks because I think they
shed some good light on you know how to
consider what data you should use and
approaches to so let me just kind of go
to sort of a very practical approach and
thinking about you know is are these
data suitable for your research
questions and I just have some examples
here that could be relevant identifying
cases you know for a particular study
observational study or prospective they
can be you know electronic health record
data can be extremely useful for a
recruitment list we've done a lot of
work in the CTSA world around you know
trying to build tools to make that
easier and other places or building
cohorts or use cases if you will and the
presence or absence of specific
variables that you know the electronic
health record is really used for so
usually diagnosis procedure codes I like
to cite because it's one of those
variables that we have become to depend
so much for billing that they tend to be
very reliable because they have to send
those data out to CMS and other places
integers but you know they're not always
perfect either but you know if you're
identifying specific events use of new
medications or procedures processes
linked to outcomes you know again when
you start to get into process kind of
work it can be a little bit murkier or
if you're trying to sequence things you
know a discus build is charged and then
looking to see what happens after that
it's an in the system does the
medication actually get prescribed and
then you know picked up and then the
whole issue of patient compliance
obviously is is you know one of those
unobserved variables in electronic
health record vital status for example I
know in the VA we have a pretty good
system for keeping track of you know
vital status while people are
experienced some sort of health care
events but once they're outside of the
healthcare environment you know you
don't always know what happens to people
and I'm not sure any electronic health
record system that may or may not be
there I was at the healthcare system
research network used to be the HM HMO
research Network on Monday and so many
of them now are talking about ways to
integrate mortality data with electronic
health record data from the various
states and from National Death Index
because they don't necessarily have
those modules and they have to go
outside to know if you know their
patients actually might have expired you
know at home or what have you so again
you may not be able to depend on the
electronic health record for vital
status characterizing subjects in a
study so you know you think about it you
want to rely on those social
characteristics again you have to think
about are those characteristics that
you're interested in really tied to
clinical care I used to think that
you know especially with like laboratory
values you know there's different ranges
for race and ethnicity so you would
think that that would make missingness
really low on race and ethnicity no it
doesn't it's a very highly missing
variable and I'll talk about an example
from that process measures you know if
you're looking at admissions discharges
visits transfers those can get a little
bit murkier but usually workload is
pretty good but if you're looking at
again any kind of process that might be
a little more tangential you know trying
to track those kind of things at a
patient level may be a little more
challenging you know and then outcomes
if you're looking at outcomes that are
within the electronic health record you
know you may know that somebody had a
readmission within 30 days if the system
keeps that or that they had a subsequent
admission but you may not know what
happened in between unless there was
some kind of a healthcare contact so
this is just you don't have to really
see the details of this but this is from
a workflow from a P quarry study that I
led focused on dialysis patients
dialysis patients they have a lot of
contact with the healthcare system and
our study was a looking at putting an
intervention in place to improve access
to primary care so we were following
patients for 18 months and it was a
mixed-methods data collection a lot of
primary data that we collected redcap
the whole bit interviews focus groups
but dialysis patients have a lot of labs
they have a lot of healthcare encounters
so relying on electronic health record
data for that so we really needed to
have that this was just a workflow for
you know how the patient's flowed
through the system and what we did and
we were really relying on the electronic
health record data but the reality is
you know some of the EHR data fields
don't get populated even some of the lab
tests why in our patient population one
of the sites we here
they rely on their dialysis equipment
for some of the lab values on the fly
and then they load it up into their data
warehouse well they miss them no so you
know every system is a little bit
different and then another issue is that
you know some value fields just aren't
valid you know BM eyes that are you know
just out of out of this world or lab
values you know uh you know hemoglobin
a1c of 48 do you really believe that
oh maybe and you know and then you know
data extraction challenge is sort of
more of the logistics you know the you
know the data are in the electronic
health record and you've worked out a
process a workflow with your you know
data stewards and your data experts
you've got your data use agreements etc
and you know the technology's just not
working no matter what you do so I want
to pause here because I want to dive
into a little bit of some of the
examples and some of the experiences
I've had and some of the fixes any
questions so far so this is another
project that we got involved with this
is one of my VA studies we in this
particular example we called a think it
was a 10% Sam random sample of VA
patients from the corporate data
warehouse these corporate data warehouse
relies exclusively on fees from the
electronic health record and this is
where we are exploring you know the
completeness of race and ethnicity data
and we kept stumbling on this in every
project that we had and trying to think
about ways that we could address this
and you know we were doing a lot of work
with both the Department of Defense all
the veterans you know have some kind of
contact with the DRG you would think but
they don't always have an affair
experience with the DoD and anyone over
65 who's in the military will have some
kind of Medicare record you would think
and so we
not the size that we might be able to
you know we were having you know missing
VA electronic health record data you
know on the order of like 50% in some in
some places and it was just you know
amazing to us that we had that kind of a
challenge and other places you know it
was really good and the reason it's
missing is because anyone want to guess
it's captured at the time that a patient
is visiting is having an encounter with
the admitting clerk or the outpatient
clerk and it's self-reported which means
the person has to ask them their race
and ethnicity and admitting clerks and
outpatient clerks don't like to ask that
question so if it's already there they
don't ask it and if it's not there
sometimes they ask and sometimes they
don't and when they do ask the question
you know sometimes it's hard to answer
the question you know people don't feel
like they fit into any particular bucket
and you know so it's sometimes you know
a person may have one response and the
clerk hears something and it doesn't fit
into their category and they have to
check some box so you can imagine you
know that sort of encounter a lot of
times it's just not asked so that's the
reason it can sometimes be missing so
what other data sources is what we
looked at you know there must be an
alternative data source
DoD must have something Medicare must
have something so this particular table
that I pulled up just shows how we use
the Medicare data to basically fill in
the blanks and the column that I have
highlighted here is the positive
predictive value using well be compared
is Medicare data to the VA z' reported
information so how how was the data that
was there
and you know did it to be actually fill
in any blanks as well so by adding
Medicare data we actually were able to
improve the completeness of the race
data by 75% it worked really well for
patients who were 65 and older some
people can be eligible for Medicare for
disability reasons younger than 65 so we
have captured some that way but it was
you know using the VA self-reported race
as the gold standard it's clear that
this is where I sort of get to the point
about people don't you know consider
themselves fitting into these categories
all the time so what Medicare is
reporting may not be necessarily
consistent with what the VA is got and
so you can see at the lower levels here
on the table the positive predictive
value goes down anyway you can see the
lower row positive predictive value for
example for Asian Pacific Islander or
other you know is only forty eight point
two whereas for folks who are in the
white non-whites black category you know
positive predictive value for the da's
self-reported status was much higher so
we did better on certain race and
ethnicity categories and less less well
on others so what does that mean for
your research it means you really have
to be careful about you know what
alternative sources you use and
sometimes you're still not going to be
able to fill in all the blanks I'll just
sort of say share that the DoD data
didn't help us a whole lot more yes
yeah we you know for this table this is
not necessarily the category that people
are asked but that's that was our you
know miscellaneous category for this
table another study that we were looking
at was focused on looking at some cancer
patients and their use of anaemia
management approaches primarily
medications we threw poetic stimulating
agents PSAs for short or blood
transfusions you think that would be in
our medical record but we wanted to you
know look at both their hemoglobin
levels what are being you know sort of
monitored think of it as he for those of
you who aren't clinically inclined the
hemoglobin levels are what triggers you
know some kind of anemia management and
usually the e SAS or a blood transfusion
are the main primary treatments and it's
what's used to monitor and patients when
they have cancers they actually can get
down really pretty low and still feel
okay there they can get you know very
exhausted tired stressed out even before
their hemoglobin starts dipping but the
reason we did this study is because they
changed some of the guidelines around
what should be the level that you start
giving some sort of treatment so a
hemoglobin level it's it's it's in every
complete blood count you can take you
know some subset of that it's it's what
you know one of the main laboratory
measures and we actually had to exclude
patients who are being treated for
cancer and treated for their anemia we
couldn't find a hemoglobin level four so
we actually of our of the you know 74
cases that we had we actually had to
exclude almost 2000 cases because as it
one of these situations where the lab
was done but we just couldn't find the
result maybe it was recorded in a note
we didn't you know look at notes we
tried to do a 10% random sample to see
if we could find you know what was going
on and we even tried to do a sensitivity
analysis revising the information you
know on our analysis based on what we
found in charts and it still was that
you know we found you know we still were
left with some missing data but it
actually helped us with you know
actually getting our manuscript
published we had actually found an
alternative source filled in the blank
where we could done a sensitivity
analysis and it didn't change our our
main outcomes but those are the kinds of
things that peer reviews are looking for
know if you are excluding that many
patients how are you addressing it and
how is it affecting your results in the
same study you know we were also looking
at you know our main outcome measure was
you know are they getting these two
treatments yes a is a parenteral
medication it can be given IV or as a
you know as a shot as an injection and
blood transfusion you know that's
obviously intravenous well as is I
mentioned sometimes these different
electronic health records have different
treatments and different packages well
it turns out in the VA II essays are
prescribed but because they're
parenteral meds they are they keep track
of those in a different place so they're
administered in the clinic most people
aren't taking those home like insulin so
trying to keep track of those things was
not in the prescription order and they
got a prescription fill it's buried in
some clinic note some place some of it
was structured and some of it wasn't
and then blood transfusion data well
that's over in the blood bank you know
they keep track of when they you know
when they dispense a you know a pint of
blood to a particular patients and where
is it in the electronic health record
varied in and out so we actually had to
exclude a good number of patients I want
to say there were about 1500 that we had
to exclude because we really didn't have
an alternative data source so you know
this is one of those things where when
it's your outcome measure
you really have to explain what's what's
missing and if you don't have you know a
good a good alternative source you know
you may be really in trouble so it's
really important to get another source
we actually had to go and do chart
reviews so let me tell you a little bit
about just sort of you know you you may
think that you know in prospective
studies I've told you about some
observational studies retrospective
observational studies this was a
prospective intervention study so no we
were right there no electronic health
record is very dynamic we're trying to
get information off of it and like you
mentioned we had this is a study where
we were studying dialysis patients so we
were getting information both from
patients and out of the electronic
health records which were different in
our two sites at a dialysis provider
site they don't have full electronic
health records so what we are accustomed
to in a large academic Medical Center
that provides a whole complement of care
you know it might not be what is at the
community health center that's focused
on behavioral health management or in
this case a dialysis provider they
aren't including information about
marital status or social determinants of
health let alone medications that are
prescribed because they don't dispense
them they track the services that they
provide and because of the nature of
their some of the facilities they track
laboratory values but even then in a
kidney
chronic kidney disease patients who are
on dialysis they literally have to meter
the dialysis dose to their laboratory
values and they usually update that on
at least a monthly basis sometimes week
to week depending upon how stable a
patient is so you know we thought our
laboratory data would be you know a
hundred percent and even that was not
just to familiarize you this list you
know we only had 216 patients ultimately
that that completed in this intervention
but what I have highlighted here on the
screen is the values that you know these
are values that are really the ones that
are important to you know manage
dialysis dosed if you will they're all
laboratory tests some of them are
calculated like the you are our
treatment adequacy and this kt / v which
is a you know it has to do with you know
the volume that is critical in
calculating the dialysis dose whereas
something like parathyroid hormone it
doesn't dictate the dialysis dose but
they might need some kind of a
supplement when those values change so
we really have to think carefully about
you know what to do with the missing
data because we are looking at these
values and you know for example
hemoglobin looking at kidney disease
quality of life so you could imagine
that if people are not getting the right
dialysis dose that it could affect their
mental mental status their physical
status and so we really wanted to make
sure that we had good values for this so
we took a statistical approach and we
used one of the imputation methods known
as multiple imputation using change
equations
I really appreciate the breviary debt is
mice not to be confused with device but
you know this was actually one of the
methods that P Khoury advocated as how
to address missingness
char's so fortunately we had a really
fabulous statistician who could
implement this for us and basically you
know what you see is you know sampling
of some of our regression results that
is you know without the imputation and
with the imputation they were thrilled
that we did this it really didn't change
our results that much in this particular
case because we have such a small sample
but I share this with you because it
really does depend on the rate of
missingness and your data why did we use
this one instead of others we actually
talked about it a lot there probably
were some choices we could have made we
didn't like the idea of using like last
observation carried forward that this
just didn't seem the most relevant and
there's some other approaches so we
really sort of thought through you know
what these values really meant to us in
the end we probably could have used any
method and it probably wouldn't have
changed our results very much and I
mentioned some of these you know just
you know choosing your methods for how
to supplement you know electronic health
record day that really depends on your
research question you know and your
level of confidence in you know some of
these factors that may be important you
know in terms of congruence or you know
reference to a gold standard you know an
in-depth chart review may not be very
practical you know if you're dealing
with thousands of patients in our p
Khoury study it was very useful we were
right there in our VA study we actually
have access to can get access with
permission to records across the country
but you know when you're dealing with
150,000 cases you know you're not going
to do a whole lot of chart reviews no
matter how many students you have
helping you you know so sampling is is
really important which it's approach we
used additional data sources may still
not be complete you know you saw that
with our Medicare data DoD data and so
you know you may still have to exclude
cases you know if it doesn't you know
meet your need I really like statistical
and imputation approaches but you still
have to be careful what you use I
personally don't have any experience
with random forests
but I know folks like to use that and
there's some really good references that
I've noted here you know mice is very
popular it's you know can use that in a
lot of different you know kinds of
modeling but I suppose you could
probably do that with random forests as
well and last observation carry forward
you know you really have to be careful
but that one depending upon what you're
studying you know for example in our
dialysis study you know if we had a lab
value in there that was from two years
ago it really would not be an
appropriate one to use for a dialysis
patient where you're dealing with a much
more acute setting so these are issues
that you really have to figure out how
to deal with depending upon your
question you know and then sort of the
last part I wanted to talk a little bit
about was just you know making sure that
you know you share your story completely
and that's kind of where the limitations
section in your in your publications
come into play but also can be more than
that you know so this is just an excerpt
from one of our studies and I think this
is the one that we did with the and
state are the ESA the hemoglobin anemia
management and you know we really relied
on in this case in this situation you
know CPT codes you know we thought that
would really get us for administering a
service administering ESA s a
transfusion but we are still not
confident that that was the best filling
so we still had to exclude some cases
you know and you know there's always
that you know we wish others would do
this this kind of 32 but there's also
you know I think increased transparency
around some of these issues one you know
in the VA for example we've really
partnered a lot in the center that I
used to direct when I was in Chicago the
VA information Resource Center we did a
lot of partnering with what we call the
operations offices in VA to you know
when we do research or when we came upon
issues around some of these challenges
with real high missingness like race and
some of the
values we'd bring it to the operation
side who would be responsive and
actually would try to address it they
actually have some we developed some
really good partners in that way and
they actually address it in the
corporate data warehouse and I'm sure
those are the kinds of things that you
can do here at OHSU as well I would have
to say that at University of Illinois it
was a little more challenging we you
know because we had a clinical research
data warehouse that fed off of the
electronic health record we could get
information and feedback back to you
know our colleagues who were the chief
information officer and the chief
medical information officer but you know
from there it kind of goes you know if
there's you know trying to make those
connections you know when you're dealing
with five different systems trying to
figure out where things are going to
change some sort of change management so
I can get very complicated but I'm still
convinced that feeding back into our
healthcare systems on the quality of
their data even if it's for research
purposes can help improve them
the other is you know it can actually
you know also now where we have a lot
more integrated tools that are bringing
information together some of the web
apps I just saw a demo this morning
where they're bringing in you know this
really nice tool to bring information
together and show you how things look
but it doesn't have any hooks back into
the electronic health record so if
something doesn't look right you know
you have to take a lot of extra steps to
kind of come back to it
but you know there may be ways to
address that too but also even in your
manuscripts you know sharing that
information you know one not only does
it inform your next study but it can
form others as well so just some summary
and I'll wrap up in case there's
questions you know you really have to
you know ask yourself is the electronic
health record the best source of data
for your study and think about what
other information you might need to
supplement I'm a big advocate of mixed
methods
studies these days yes even qualitative
data you know can be extremely valuable
and also for you know some process
measures you know understanding the
process you know we're doing a lot of
work now in care coordination and
understanding that business process and
does it even show up in the electronic
health record or any of the tools that
link into it and how is really important
if you're gonna relate those processes
to any kind of outcome you know try to
plan ahead in preventing and monitoring
missing data and trying to you know get
a handle on that before it's a problem
considering statistical issues to
address some of the missingness
alternative data sources we talked about
and then you know sensitivity analysis
has been around forever and it really is
important if you're considering you know
how to share this information with
others in peer review and frankly and
grant proposals too and finding ways not
to report it only in publications but in
other venues your operational partners
your learning healthcare system likes to
get feedback so everyone has a story to
tell I'm sure those of you who have used
electronic health records yourselves
probably have both the positives and the
negatives and good advice for everybody
so I hope I've given you some good
advice today and share some perspectives
happy to take questions
[Applause]
thank you for that I'm curious whether
any of the data warehouses you've worked
with their projects you've done have
involved oral health data that's come
from dental offices and dental health
record systems particularly in whether
they do have the same kind of missing
data problems with the social
determinants of health or could be a
good kind of complementary data source
for filling in now that kind of dentists
are doing more with care home yeah
that's really a fabulous idea I know I
personally have not worked with dental
records in the VA we actually have
dental records as a module but it
probably might I don't know if it has
any additional information that would be
beyond what what else is already there
but I would imagine in the private
sector that could be very very helpful
there's OHS you do dental
yeah
I'm telling you I went out the last time
I was at my dentist the amount of
granularity that they have in those
databases I just he's got his nice
little screen talking to you and all I
could think of is Wow
you know what's at the back end of that
system but I'll bet you know I'm
imagining because I'm seeing this and
you know some of the you know small
private practices they may not own that
well they may own the data but they may
be contracting with a vendor that keeps
track of it in some kind of you know
consortium sort of warehouse so trying
to use that data for certain research I
could imagine could be pretty
complicated can you just say that our
Kaiser started integrating their dental
and medical data for someone who used to
be here who is actually I think a
doctoral student in your school of
public yeah it was actually if it part
of epic or is it separate do you think I
don't know I just know and that was a
project she was involved in after she
left here Kaiser uses epic so it must be
but axiom is actually used by a lot of
academic dental schools and I don't know
the extent to which it integrates but
you know this is always a challenge
although if there were standards and
people adhere to them it might be less
of an issue who the vendor is but of
course we're not there yet yeah I know
with you know we worked with a dialysis
provider for zinnias and they have
pretty sophisticated network and data
warehouse that they use for all of their
systems but it's you know it's only a
sliver of care but it's a pretty
important sliver although these days now
they're expanding into you know the full
complements of care so it's not just
dialysis anywhere other questions
how many of you are making use of the
oak tree data warehousing I'm gonna I'm
gonna get on that list but I never
gotten on the list yet
is there any hope thank you this is
great talk is there any hope for a
lining provider and and researcher
incentives to so that as this data is
collected it's understood to have
quality you know for that research that
the clinician might actually share some
investment in to to merge these these
interests yeah I mean I think it really
depends on from institution the
institution
I mean tell me about OHSU I'm still
learning you know in the VA they
actually have a data quality office and
what they really I'm so I was surprised
in the VA and I you know been in the
game for a long time I thought their
data quality efforts would be sort of no
you you think of data quality on a
continuum there's you know sort of
frontline when things are coming in or
being collected all the way down to the
data warehouse and as a researcher we
tend to focus on you know that more of
that end state well that's where the
data quality office focuses to I was we
were just stunned that that's sort of
where their focus was and I mean they've
been very responsive and they will you
know get the message back to you know
who's ever managing the software you
know on the front end but they're really
not looking at it until it's already at
the data warehouse stage mostly for
Identity Management which is huge and
fixing it there so there's so much now I
think is just you know it gets there to
the data warehouse so fast maybe they
can fix it and get it back into you know
the front end I'm not really sure I was
I was surprised that data quality wasn't
being addressed sort of earlier on
enough in a cycle yeah I'm not sure that
actually it's too bad dr. Gore had to
leave a little early to see well lesson
because yeah I'm not sure it's a
a huge thing I mean again one silver
lining on this you know is the new you
know proposed rules that have come from
the 21st century cure act that is
starting to get a lot more prescriptive
about you know use for example a fire
and and and various control terminology
so so there may be hope but I you know I
guess the question though is if the data
is not all being stored in the right
place and you know I don't I don't know
how much standards is gonna help that if
it you know the data just gets put
somewhere else you know I guess maybe is
it possible that well again maybe a kind
of researcher clinician collaboration or
maybe as healthcare organizations move
in more data-driven directions because
of accountable care organizations or
whatever maybe that might help to solve
some of these problems it does make me a
little nervous with so much attention on
you know machine learning and AI you
know there's been a couple you know
really major papers written you know
deep medicine and you know some of the
other ones that just came out in the
last couple of months you know it's the
same mantra we've had around you know
bad data in bad outcomes out you know
you have to have the right data to work
with you know in the first place it
doesn't matter what algorithm AI machine
learning ordinary least-squares
regression if the data aren't there or
if they're not representing what's true
you know you're not gonna get a good
outcome but it is fun to do all these
you know different different techniques
you still got a question whether you
know the data that you were working with
our legitimate
well thank you very much glad to be here
[Applause]